or I have family there,
but that a rural child lives within this shiny visage of fabulosity.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
I invited the Motswana public into the story, my story,
as a transgender person years ago, in English of course,
because Setswana is a gender-neutral language
and the closest we get is an approximation of "transgender."
And an important part of my history got left out of that story,
by association rather than out of any act of shame.
"Kat" was an international superstar,
a fashion and lifestyle writer, a musician, theater producer
and performer --
all the things that qualify me to be a mainstream, whitewashed,
new age digestible queer.
Kat.
Kat had a degree from one of the best universities in Africa,
oh no, the world.
By association, what Kat wasn't
was just like the little brown-skinned children
frolicking through the streets of some incidental railway settlement
like Tati Siding,
or an off-the-grid village like Kgagodi,
legs clad in dust stockings whose knees had blackened
from years of kneeling and wax-polishing floors,
whose shins were marked with lessons from climbing trees,
who played until dusk,
went in for supper by a paraffin lamp
and returned to play hide-and-seek amongst centipedes and owls
until finally someone's mother would call the whole thing to an end.
That got lost both in translation and in transition,
and when I realized this,
I decided it was time for me to start building bridges between myselves.
For me and for others to access me,
I had to start indigenizing my queerness.
What I mean by indigenizing is stripping away the city life film
that stops you from seeing the villager within.
In a time where being brown, queer, African and seen as worthy of space
means being everything but rural,
I fear that we're erasing the very struggles
that got us to where we are now.
The very first time I queered being out in a village,
I was in my early 20s, and I wore a kaftan.
I was ridiculed by some of my family and by strangers for wearing a dress.
My defense against their comments was the default that we who don't belong,
the ones who are better than, get taught,
we shrug them off and say, "They just don't know enough."
And of course I was wrong, because my idea of wealth of knowledge
was based in removing yourself from Third World thinking and living.
But it took time for me to realize that my acts of pride
weren't most alive in the global cities I traipsed through,
but in the villages where I speak the languages and play the games
and feel most at home and I can say,
"I have seen the world,
and I know that people like me aren't alone here, we are everywhere."
And so I used these village homes for self-reflection
and to give hope to the others who don't belong.
Indigenizing my queerness
means bridging the many exceptional parts of myself.
It means honoring the fact
that my tongue can contort itself to speak the romance languages
without denying or exoticizing the fact that when I am moved, it can do this:
(Ululating)
It means --
(Cheers)
(Applause)
It means branding cattle with my mother or chopping firewood with my cousins
doesn't make me any less fabulous or queer,
even though I'm now accustomed to rooftop shindigs, wine-paired menus
and VIP lounges.
(Laughter)
It means wearing my pride through my grandmother's tongue,
my mother's food, my grandfather's song,
my skin etched with stories of falling off donkeys
and years and years and years of sleeping under a blanket of stars.
If there's any place I don't belong,
it's in a mind where the story of me starts with the branch of me being queer
and not with my rural roots.
Indigenizing my queerness means understanding
that the rural is a part of me, and I am an indelible part of it.
Thank you.
(Applause)